c'est un alchimiste cyr au pied de la
vallée de chevreuse avec ses recettes il
fait face aux conséquences de la crise
sanitaire
il poursuit la fabrication et la vente
de ces sirops mais a fermé son bar et
cesser toute animation d'ateliers
conséquence directe une perte de 40% de
son chiffre d'affaires au mois de mars
on a dû effectivement se réorganiser
puisqu'on est deux à travailler
evelyne et en chômage partiel c'est
comme ça qu'on a pu
travailler parce que sinon c'était
ingérable d'avoir de salaire
effectivement à temps plein ici vu de la
baisse d'activité dans cette nouvelle
organisation marque chenu travaille seul
tous les jours de 7h à 22h
en temps normal près de 2000 bouteilles
sont produites en moyenne par mois avec
la crise sanitaire marque chez nous n'en
produit plus que mme il faut savoir que
pour arriver à comment dire à maintenir
le cap c'est à dire éviter la
catastrophe
j'ai pas dire se développer d éviter la
catastrophe contre je travaille deux
fois plus pour deux formes d'art et donc
que j'ai fait appel effectivement des
producteurs locaux à des commerces
locaux pour pouvoir me fournis en
matière première ce qui a pu se faire
donc il ya une solidarité qui s'est mise
en place une solidarité aussi venant de
ses clients notamment à travers des
commandes sur internet
la principale source de son activité
aujourd'hui
face à la baisse de son activité marche
nu a demandé aussi un recours au fonds
de solidarité et un rééchelonnement des
créances faut savoir qu'une entreprise
en général c'est 60 70 % de charge sa
masse salariale
donc ça pas un effort au niveau des
charges beaucoup d'entreprises risquent
de péricliter
l'artisan estime aujourd'hui que les
charges salariales lui coûte près de
3000 euros par mois